what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time while while
she's trying to get rich
my sister's trying to get her lunch
money right i'm here with polina
she's got a sailor a sailor outfit on
all good what's going on with china
it's friday by the way oh sponsor that's
right block five don't forget block five
is the sponsor
get money get paid three products you
put in crypto they give you a us dollar
loan
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange
and my favorite product the one i use is
the interest bearing account
you put in money either crypto or
dollars and they pay you up to eight
point six percent
apy your bank pays you nothing basically
they pay you like 0.05 percent
block file pay 8.6 in an interest
bearing account
go click on the link in the description
so we get credit
and tell them that we sent you what's
going on with
china okay so twitter is deleting
more than 170 000 accounts tied to
chinese propaganda efforts
how are they how what are you doing
sorry i'm laughing my brothers are
sitting over here on the other side of
the table and they're videoing me
because they think they're funny but go
keep going what's going on with china
so it's deleting accounts tied to
chinese propaganda efforts
how do they know how to target these
accounts
well i mean they basically figure out
through uh what is the ip address
what's the similarities between it right
there's all kinds of different ways that
they can
uh identify it they probably don't let
people know what the actual criteria is
of how they're
uh finding out uh these accounts because
they don't want the patterns to then be
changed right so the more that they can
figure out the patterns
and use them to to um uh identify these
accounts and get rid of them the better
and what i think is pretty cool is they
actually released all the information
they were super transparent about like
there's like 150
000 accounts that we found that are
linked to nation states and basically
propaganda
we're getting rid of them here's all the
information like if you want to
investigate this knock yourself out are
they going to do the same for the united
states where do you draw the line
well i think part of it is uh in the u.s
there's definitely troll accounts or
boxes okay can you call them troll
accounts not propaganda accounts
well of course propaganda and marketing
are the same things just whether you
agree with it or not
right propaganda is just marketing you
don't agree with uh in terms of
um in the us though i think the whole
thing really is
uh what they are doing is they are
spreading geopolitical news favorable to
the communist party
and so twitter obviously stand
both in the united states and outside
right so they started to label tweets in
the u.s
uh they're going against anybody who is
promoting uh
communist information and so we'll see
what happens there
what uh but they're not the only one
who's going after china yeah they're not
so zoom uh close the account of a
us-based chinese
activist to comply with local law that
but that's not going after china though
it's
kind of complying with it i got to call
complete [ __ ] on zoom on this one
i'm a big fan i use the product but what
essentially happened is the chinese
government is sending
uh the names of users to zoom
and saying shut down this account shut
down this account and what
zoom did uh over the last couple of days
is there's
four separate uh accounts where people
were
holding um events to celebrate tiananmen
square
and they shut down the meetings in the
middle of the recording
they're not celebrating the event they
were commemorating
there's a difference same thing and in
terms of
uh in the middle of the meeting they
shut it down and then they
banned the user that started it they've
since reinstated
three of the users because they're
outside of china so one was in hong kong
two were in the united states
but what they're now saying is like oh
we're gonna build technology so that we
can
ban people or prevent them from
participating in zooms based on their
geography
so if the chinese government comes to us
and says hey shut down this account
they're based in china they will comply
if it says hey shut down this account or
this meeting but it's being held by
somebody outside of china
they will not comply so okay so
how come zoom it's a u.s based company
what the hell are its ties to china
maybe it's us-based
it is us-based maybe reportedly how do
you know
that's what it says there's a lot of
companies that are believed to be based
in the united states but are also
rumored to be controlled by china do we
think that kind of uh this scrutiny of
zoom is also going to translate uh and
bleed into
other companies like tick tock well
their tick tock's already under fire
tim in my perspective by the way just
saw him clear i don't think that china
controls zoom or the ccp controls zoom
but i do think that this is complete
[ __ ] that they're not taking a stand
and telling the chinese government
that we're not going to censor people
that's what they're doing they're
literally censoring people based on
content uh
and they are um really just uh cozying
up to the chinese government they're
saying sure send us whatever you want
and we'll censor people
i don't think that they should do that
tick tock as far as we know is not doing
that the concerns are on tick tock it's
not sensor or shift it's the data
collection
yeah and surveillance and things like
that which might not be better
but i do think that we've seen companies
in the past like
facebook who said we're not going to
comply uh
they haven't been allowed in china you
see things like google um
there is rumors that google has allowed
uh for censorship right
and even some proof to it and so it just
comes down to like where do you stand as
a company are you gonna put profits and
uh the financial performance ahead of
what you stand for
from a political standpoint some people
choose to do that way i just don't agree
with it
yep fair yeah fair um facebook
[ __ ] communism so we were talking about
this
last time uh or sorry last time last
night that's why you
your dad and i get along [ __ ] communism
okay
kids watch this show oh yeah kids show
sorry
um facebook venture team so do you
remember when the other night when i was
saying how
basically nobody uses facebook anymore
and
kind of our generation uses tick-tock
but maybe the teenager
sorry instagram but the teenagers used
tik-tok um and i was asking you if
there's like a world where
facebook could buy tick-tock okay well
probably not but facebook has been
hiring seasoned tech investors to help
lead a new multi-million dollar
investment fund so a new venture arm
within facebook
um to invest in social apps before they
become
big so basically they don't want to miss
out on the next tick tock
yeah i mean look every team's been doing
this for a lot like google adventures
has been around forever right so
facebook's actually late to the game
here uh interesting is uh they went and
they got
uh shabee rizvi who used to be at google
ventures
i've met him before incredibly smart guy
um who's gonna help them
uh manage this fund they also have a
couple of people that they're hiring
full-time it sounds like
uh i just think that this whole game
is very well understood by most social
media companies and technology
companies you invest early and then you
get to see everything and kind of get an
inside track
that's not going to help you with
something like tick tock which you just
missed
um and also it's part of a different
company
yeah it's just but it could help you in
the future yeah do you think that
they're doing it for a financial return
facebook yeah or do you think it's just
for the like market intelligence
competitive analysis yeah i think that's
for market intelligence and probably
because when you invest
you're kind of like i might buy you in
the future
do we think it's do we think it's over
or under 50 million
i think it's right around 50. i think
it's under really
yeah they're not saying but the reason
why i think it's under
is my guess is that they want to do
super early seed investing okay but hold
on so
i mean facebook has the kind of capital
to just buy startups
right yeah so why are they now just now
creating a venture fund
well the whole idea is basically i don't
want to spend all the money to buy you
right so let's let's say that a company
is raising their seed round
at a 12 to 15 million valuation right
they're raising three million bucks 12
million dollar pre 15 million
post i can spend 15 million dollars and
buy you i might even have to pay a
premium to actually get you to sell me
the company because you as the founder i
think it's gonna be worth more in the
future
so rather than buy you and spend you
know 20 million bucks
i can just give you half a million
dollars now i have information rights
your company
i get to see how it goes and if it turns
out to be something super big i'll buy
you for 50 million right
but i basically hedge and get an option
on the future
but as to flip it as a startup founder
of a hot new social media app
would you want facebook as an investor
in your company that's what uh
that's going to be the big debate some
people are going to see that as a huge
advantage and huge stamp of validation
others are going to say i want facebook
to skip my data and see my information
that's been going on forever right like
google ventures how many people want
google venture money actually a lot of
people right there's some who say they
don't
but the gv is pretty separate from
google
allegedly yeah allegedly
you don't think that they share
information uh no
it says google ventures no they just
google it
they changed it to gv because they
didn't want it associated
that's like me saying my name's anthony
pamplemeter wait i changed it to ap
come on my name's still anthony pompeo
okay okay
we got my brother right here who said
facebook and instagram he said they're
supposed to be a part but they're not
apart
that's a that's vinnie numbers over
there he's just got his little uh
spreadsheets out he's rocking
he broke the internet okay
um america hey
american airlines baby
okay well so we lost the internet here
for a second
second quarter revenue down 90 percent
i mean which is an improvement what do
you mean improvement from what
second quarter revenue for american
airlines is rumored they're projecting
it's gonna be down 90
uh which is up from where it was before
they were down more than 90 percent
um originally thought and so uh look
they lost 90
because no one got on a plane because
the government literally said hey all
you peasants got gotta go sit inside
or you're gonna get arrested wait a
second how how is it saying that it
expects to cut its cash burn rate to
about
zero by the end of 2020 well okay so
this is important so
basically they were a profitable company
meaning that they
made more money every day than they
spent then
the pandemic hit and the government
literally forced everyone to go sit at
home
like you know just cattle and just made
everyone listen to whatever the
government says
and so when that happened obviously no
one was booking to fly on planes
so now they were spending more money
than they were making so they had a
negative net cash burn every day yeah
right now it's rumored that in june they
are going to
through very very tough measures
get to a negative 40 million dollar
cash burn so they're gonna lose 40
million dollars a day by the end of june
that's an improvement from how much they
were losing before
and that's going to continue to improve
so to go from 40 to 35 to 30 to 10
million
and eventually by the end of the year
they'll get back to break even where
they'll be
uh making just as much money in a day as
they're spending and let me tell you i
got
intel that american airlines is not
doing social distancing with
nobody sitting in a middle seat the
planes are packed how do you
what's intel i got i got until i got
sources don't ask what intel do you have
next british airways i'll tell the
people we got on a plane
but not not recently like a couple of
days like a week ago
when i got my hair cut i had to go
somewhere so dumb i can't
okay it's fine i wore a mask british
airways
wipe down the uh the seat british
airways is also struggling and to kind
of
help itself it's planning to auction off
are worth millions
i mean it's literally taking the art
that it has
in airports and putting it up for
auction good
this is what they should be doing is
this do you think that uh because of
coronavirus a lot of these companies no
matter if you're an airline or a small
business or whatever
uh you're gonna just find multiple
streams of income no this is the whole
problem
is the airlines the second that the
economic crisis hit
they all ran and went to the government
and asked for a bailout it's socialism
that's all that is that is literally
socialism they found the dumbest person
in the room and they begged for free
money and the government was stupid
enough to give it to him
so now what we're seeing is in other
countries like british airways
over in europe they're saying wait a
second we should actually
try to get as much capital onto our
balance sheet as possible they look
around at all the assets they only like
we don't need this
fine art that's worth millions of
dollars why don't we sell the art
so that we have cash on our balance
sheet that's what we should have forced
american companies to do that's pretty
crazy
well why did the government give uh five
plus billion dollars to some of these
companies right i think it was a 50
billion dollar
bailout package and two-thirds of it was
for free
we got no equity we got no loans no
anything out of it
i just don't think that 1.3 million
dollars is enough to
supplement anything for british airways
agreed but it but it's the principle of
the fact that they should be forced to
do everything that they can to put cash
in their balance sheet before they get
money from a government
okay fair fair yeah is there a nice art
i don't know
um okay so this is
space force this is great so
netflix created this show called space
force it's a netflix original comedy
and it's based on the new branch of the
military that trump
created and now netflix has obtained
the trademark rights for the name before
the government i mean
but this is great but can the government
not use the name now
i think they have to pay netflix right
the show secured trademark rights to
space force in multiple places including
europe australia and mexico while the
air force owns only a pending
application for registration in the
united states
so really what this means though is uh
the us military has the trademark for
space force in the u.s
or as a pending application netflix
didn't get it in the u.s but they got
the
trademark in other countries yeah
so what's gonna happen like are they
gonna have to change the name of a
military branch
because of uh netflix that would be
amazing who's more powerful the us
military or
netflix can you what do you think you
are if you're a general and you're
like [ __ ] netflix has this trademark
well you better be smart
uh space force is netflix's billionth
show one billion that they've created or
that they have on their platforms
yeah i mean by the way the fact that we
have a space force
is one was comical at first but two
if you actually see what they're doing
uh like they're like super legit they
got like
uniforms they got badges they've got
technology like they're going all out on
this thing
and my uh question to you is do you
think that the space force will have
more or less funding
than the us navy in 20 years who gets
more funding
it depends who's president why
i mean can't the next president just
shut it down
they could but do you think that it's
gonna be more important to defend
space and have military capabilities in
space or
i think still over land really or it's
over water but yeah
whatever the whole life the whole idea
though is i feel like most of the wars
being fought
here on earth are moving towards cyber
wars like china is a great example
we're going to have a war where we
infiltrate china or china infiltrates
the united states it's going to be all
fought
uh economically cyber warfare like that
type of stuff
and so maybe there's like threat of
force with the navy
but the odds that the u.s navy is going
to actually engage in
violent combat with china is like near
zero so why don't we have do we have a
cyber
force well we're very good our cyber
capabilities are the best in the world
we're so great we don't need any more
uh capabilities that's what we claim
i mean you could argue that north korea
has some of the best cyber capabilities
in the world
they've been hacking banks and all kinds
of places sony
yeah they have sony i mean that's how
they're funding their country still
right it's all through cyber war for the
most part if you look at their
the estimations of north korea's uh
revenue sources
it's like majority of it comes through
cyber crime
right that's how they fund all their
operations it's really interesting well
maybe we should have a cyber force
instead of a space force i don't care
about the aliens
yet if the aliens come here
we're screwed i know but we're always
going to be screwed we have no idea what
the aliens would bring or look like
yeah but it just sounds good like we can
just tell them like hey we have a cyber
for we have a space force
like we could shoot our lasers and yeah
protect ourselves
you don't like that i think if the
aliens come we're just screwed all right
surprise
surprise i have a question for you to
end on a friday
what's one thing you learned this week
that you didn't know before
the week started oh god i forgot what we
talked about this week give me some
topics
no what's one thing you learned this
week doesn't have to be from lunch money
i learned oh i was gonna say i learned
that you can't count to 80.
but um another thing
oh okay i learned that um elon musk's
sister um has
something that she founded called
passionflix which is like a netflix for
uh romance novels so like uh nicholas
sparks movies
i think like a little more raunchy oh
it's like
like porn no like less raunchy
oh i'll like softcore porn no oh you'll
tell me later
i mean this is just family here with the
lunch money crew like what are you
talking about they know what i'm talking
about just look at passionflix
like what sounds like either porn or not
what did you learn
uh i learned a lot actually this week um
i would probably say that my biggest
lesson learned though was
uh that i'm perfect i already did that
uh it's not
turing it's the fourth turning the end
is really important in there
people got very upset when i didn't use
them also i have one thing for you
to learn it's not egg especially it's
especially
don't you're not going to correct my
english if i want that's the beauty of
being an american
is you could be ignorant and just talk
however you want to talk you ever heard
something from the south talk they don't
that's not even england that's like a
whole other language
right you ever heard a new yorker talk
is that english i don't know
we just have our own little dialogue
okay where are you from especially
because i'm from uh
florida drives me crazy okay
let's let's move on y'all ever heard of
making north carolina
[Applause]
all right lunch money time here's the
deal a bunch of you've been complaining
we hear your complaints
that you don't have twitter accounts so
a hundred dollars we're giving away on
friday because it's lunch money time
and so if you want to be entered to win
the hundred dollars
you have to go and sign up for the email
list
it is the top pinned comment in the
comment section go
click on the link put in your email when
you put your email in
all you're going to do is every day
you're going to get us to email you
the episode of lunch money so you don't
miss it but
one of you who signs up on the email
list this week
we will pick email you we'll send you a
hundred bucks you can go get dinner
or whatever you want to be signed up
then you're out
sorry nope you're screwed go sign up for
the email list
one of you is gonna get a hundred
dollars lunch money
you can tell us what you're gonna do
with it after you get it that's it for
lunch money realize people might
unsubscribe just to be subscribed that's
fine okay hey if you want to be
smart go be smart that's fine but just
so we're clear
this is uh look i got both of my look
this one he really doesn't want to be
seen on camera but now he's live
now he's
all live that's it for lunch money this
week guys while wall street's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right we'll see you
guys on monday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
black lives my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends